happy happy monday everyone yeah we're
back we ate like fiends and drank like
ghouls and now we're back at work asking
the makeup people to hide our neck fat
except for cat for her a four-day
thanksgiving bender is just three days
shy of her normal week
tyrus is back and this is how he cooked
his thanksgiving turkey
[Music]
there we go joe mackey is here good to
see you joe
yeah
uh yeah oh he gets applause
uh he was just on tour he just got back
here's one audience reaction to his
stand up
[Applause]
yep was that good
now sometimes in the media you end up in
dangerous places the weird thing is
often the dangerous places the media
goes to were mainly created by the media
themselves it's like someone having a
bad acid trip it's totally self-induced
cat understands
take last year's riots the media bravely
covered it calling it mostly peaceful
because nothing says mostly peaceful
like a man shot dead protecting his
business
that giant lie handicapped the police so
they couldn't do a damn thing to stop
the riots without being accused of
attacking mostly peaceful protesters the
media protected the mob so the cities
burned and people died and this moved
beyond the riots to a nationwide crime
wave because as long as you dismiss the
crime you create more crime you can do
it with words here's a recent tweet by
cnn waukesha
wakasha will hold a moment of silence
today marking one week since a car a car
drove through a city christmas parade
killing six people and injuring scores
of others
so a car drove through a parade not a
racist madman but a car they got it
didn't have a driver it could have been
worse this from a network that takes
pains to uncover any human responsible
for a silly meme that hurts their
feelings but here a massacre is caused
by an inanimate object they blame it on
a curling iron if they thought they
could get away with it and suddenly the
media is no longer interested in
domestic terrorism they'll also label a
black politician a white supremacist but
when the suspect has more racist social
media than louis farrakhan it's the car
at fault
but you get it when you're in the media
identifying who is responsible must be
avoided if it makes you seem racist to
the activist class so focus on the
object and hope the public is as stupid
as you think it is you can run over a
christmas parade and kill twice as many
people as the boston marathon bombers
and they'll call it an accident the soft
bigotry of low expectations turns into
crime and murder because they believe
minorities are responsible for
themselves
now we have organized looting the
question isn't why it's happening it's
why the hell not if you're a criminal
it's like stealing stevie wonder's
french fries
this risk is tiny compared to
mugging or drug dealing here you can
easily overrun a business and steal 900
bucks worth of stuff per person that's
the law in california so forget robbing
a guy coming off a shift at arby's all
you get is 50 bucks and you end up
smelling like a roast beef sandwich
they now have decriminalized crime and
the risk is nil they might as well
advertise it on tv it's black friday
every day and everything's marked down
100 the first hundred customers busting
through a storefront window gets a flat
screen in victim status
the media will say don't call it looting
because that's racist perhaps even
covering these crimes at all is racist
too criminals understand this as they
see democrats are more worried about
protecting people from old statues than
active crime scenes as retail dies
amazon must be grinning until the next
wave goes after their drivers they'll be
the new stage coaches but instead of
guns their drivers will defend
themselves with bottles of urine
now if you're in the media chances are
you're protected as i tape this show we
have security they make sure the fans in
this audience don't attack me which
happens when you're this sexy
some nights i feel like tom jones trying
to get to this his dressing room at the
sahara you 80 year olds know what i mean
but we have security especially when we
go outside like when jesse gets his hair
cut
super cuts can get chaotic especially
since jesse never tips
but what happens to those who try to
protect the media from the story that
they try to cover kevin nishida a
security guard was shot and killed
trying to protect the carrow and tv news
crew while covering a smash and grab in
the bay area as he tried to stop thugs
trying to steal the crew's equipment he
was murdered he was a former cop who
just retired he had a wife and kids
unlike aoc's criminals he was actually
trying to feed his family
will this wake the media up that crime
is out of control when those helping you
cover it lose their lives will his death
remind the media that there's a cost in
redefining crime as a form of protest
will his death have any effect on those
who see crime
as a joke
like seth rogen
when a guy on twitter claimed he was
robbed in la rogan blamed the victim
saying don't leave anything valuable in
the car it's called living in a big city
he added he'd been raw before in that
quote once a guy accidentally left a
cool knife in my car so if it keeps
happening you might get a little treat
the guy's so out of touch he pretends
being a crime victim is delightful no
wonder he's typecast as an idiot
but what if the next time that knife is
left not in your car but in your back
seth hasn't had to think about that he's
rich it's easy for him to rebound from
victimization plus he's always armed
with box office poison
now just imagine if our detectives
ignored victims when they report crimes
i hear you're the best detective in town
and i want to hire you what for it nuts
my store 15 people robbed it yesterday
oh this is the big city that's a
misdemeanor get used to it
but
i'm ruined they took everything what you
dames don't understand is when you move
on the sticks you got to take the view
with the bat the bad is you're
constantly being robbed you're over
taxed and homeless people poop in your
yard the good is
hey we used to have restaurants
now if you'll excuse me
i'm moving to texas i gotta help beto
o'rourke get a personality
i have no idea what accent that was but
i liked it now maybe the media should
consider the sacrifice made by people
like mr nishita so they could cover
their stories nishida was shot dead by a
thug or as cnn might describe it a
bullet drove through the air and struck
a man who happened to be in its path